>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Tomoko Steen:
Welcome, everyone.
This is sponsored by
science, technology,
and business division.
I'm Tomoko Steen.
I'm a research specialist at the
library's science, technology,
and business division.
Today's speaker is cyber
security discussion.
It's going to be
very interesting.
He is Professor Jean-Pierre
Auffret
at George Mason University.
And he's a director of
a research partnership
in the school of business,
and also associate director
of the Center for Assurance
Research and Engineering
in the school of engineering.
He's currently also
a visiting lecturer
at Duke Sanford School
of Public Policy.
He has a PhD in physics,
and also MBA
from the University of Virginia.
And his PhD is from
American University.
He has a chemistry undergraduate
degree from Duke University.
Cyber security is really
close to our lives,
and from communication
to medical research,
and also the medical
devices are now, you know,
cyber security really involved.
So before further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Professor Auffret.
[ Applause ]
>> J.P. Auffret:
Thank you, Tomoko.
And thank you all
for joining today.
It's a real pleasure to visit
the Library of Congress again,
and to meet all of you.
Just real quickly,
the main focus
of the talk is both domestically
and internationally what some
of the challenges
and innovations
and approaches are
to cyber security.
As part of that, I'm going
to start with a little bit
of background and context both
on the changing technology
landscape,
but also changing cyber
security landscape.
And then wrap up with
international relations
and some on future trends.
A little bit of background
of our cyber security center
where -- A research
to practice center.
And has a range of technical
projects and policy projects
as well as leadership
and governance.
So some of the current ones
we have are two projects
with DARPA.
One on distributed
denial of service,
and one on internet of things.
Trying to ascertain whether
a device has been compromised
by change in the electromagnetic
field or power consumption.
Then had a recent project
with IBM on smart grid,
and then two projects,
leadership and governance
with the National
Science Foundation,
one on developing
core competencies
for cheaper information security
officers, and a new one working
with cities and counties
across the country
on fostering cyber security
partnering amongst cities
and counties.
The idea being that many cities
and counties are relatively
small and have limited expertise
and budgets, and
there's a great potential
for them partnering together.
So as some background I
think on the landscape
and the technology landscape,
I think these two are --
circumstances are
really quite amazing,
and illustrate the increasing
importance of technology in day
to day lives and in society.
The one on the upper left is
the digital identity in India.
So the Indian government
has a digital India program,
and about five years
ago undertook a program
to provide everyone in the
country over the age of five
with a digital identity.
So part of the motivation is 80%
of India lives in rural areas,
and with 1.3 billion
people total,
it's about 1 billion people.
So it would make it one
of the biggest countries
in the world, just
the rural areas.
And many of those in the rural
areas did not have identities,
drivers' licenses or another
type of government identity.
And, in fact, many of the
women's identities were
through their husband, and
they didn't have their own
actual identity.
And so as a way of fostering
economic growth, partially also
to address corruption,
the Indian government
undertook this program.
So it's quite a large challenge
to provide unique identities
to a billion people.
And so the way they did
it was with iris scans
and taking 10 fingerprints.
And the program has
since broadened.
So not just for identity.
The Indian government now
trying to replace paper currency
with digital currency also uses
this [inaudible] for mobile,
mobile SIM chips,
really becoming more
and more a part of society.
Of course there's issues and
challenges with cyber security
and privacy, but the Indian
government sees it as a way
to truly catalyze the
country in the coming years.
Then on the bottom
right, Estonia,
considered the most digital
country in the world,
really kind of interesting.
They only had a few
years of independence
for the last 700 years until
the early 1990s and the 1920s.
And if you go to the Estonian
embassy there's a letter
welcoming the [inaudible]
by Calvin Coolidge welcoming the
Estonia ambassador to the U.S.
for that short number of years.
But after they became
independent they really tried
to develop an IT industry.
They had a history of computer
science from the soviet years,
and Microsoft chose them as
a test bed for new products.
And so the Estonian
government developed a consensus
that they were going to
compete as a small country
in the ICT space, that they'd
digitize the government
for the most part, founded
Skype, and now a number
of other companies, but
really totally reliant on ICT.
And also totally reliant
on cyber security.
So those are two examples where
more and more so in the world --
I think IT puts out [inaudible]
reports every year measuring the
information society.
This is from last
year's, I believe.
Really remarkable
that the blue line
on the upper part is
mobile phone adoption.
I'm sorry.
The -- The orange line
is mobile phone adoption.
And so pretty much 100
subscriptions per 100 people
around the world.
Even in rural areas and
developing countries
so that the cell phone has
tremendous power, and more
and more like a computer.
One other interesting
note on this slide.
The dark green one is
mobile broadband adoption,
and that's even faster
than mobile phone adoption.
So more and more
countries have industries --
Well, mobile banking,
such as M-PESA in Kenya.
And the motivation for that
is the country might have 20%
or 30% of the country
has a bank account.
90% or 100% have cell phones.
So the cell phone
providing an avenue
for banking and other services.
Here, too, this is just in
the last number of years.
Only recently, the last 10 years
or so, did submarine cables land
in West Africa, and East
Africa it was just a little bit
before that.
A follow on to that.
Many, many countries are now
developing fiber backbone
networks in Africa.
With that, the cost of cell
phone and availability coming
down rapidly in the country,
becoming more and more reliant
on IT and at risk
from cyber security.
Just a little background
on what's driving the
technology change in the areas
of computer storage, processing
speed, and transmission speed.
And these trends continue.
So it was just in 1980
that the first 1 gigabyte
of storage became
commercially available.
It was about the size
of a refrigerator
and weighed 550 pounds,
and cost $40,000.
So today we can all
go to a microcenter
and buy several terabytes
for $50.
So that trend continuing.
Similarly, with transmission,
only in 1957 the first
Transatlantic cable, and only 36
or so simultaneous phone calls
for many dollars a minute.
Today 3 or 4 million calls
on a fiber optic cable.
And that trend continuing too.
And lastly, processing speed.
By coincidence, the
first Apple computer,
as well as the first
lunar lander,
both had processing speeds of
about 2,000 cycles a second.
Now 6, 7, 8 billion
cycles a second.
So as much as technology
has changed
over the last 30 years
today, it's hard to imagine
with these trends
continuing, where it will be
in 10, 20, or 30 years.
And there too what
the cyber risks are.
Of course much written
and much being done
on the sustainable
development goals.
And some really interesting work
and many interesting initiatives
on the role of ICT and all of
these, but also too the risk
of cyber attack and the
importance of cyber security.
One of the more interesting
initiatives I think is Japan's
Society 5.0 partially to
address demographic trends
or -- in society.
Or decreasing population.
Also to stay competitive, but
Japan looking to embed even more
so ICT and all the
infrastructure in their approach
to all there is of society.
So Japan with a very large focus
on ICT, but a very large focus
on cyber security too.
And then lastly on some of the
main challenges and issues,
this is a World Economic
Forum report, I believe.
World Economic Forum report.
And so it's not all
about the technology.
The left-hand side has
institutional capacity,
and across the bottom
has technology capacity.
And you can see the country's
fallen in different sides
of the 45 degree line.
Some countries much stronger
and have much more developed
institutional capacity,
like legal frameworks
and ICT governance
and ICT leadership
and government.
Privacy policy.
Others are much stronger
in technology,
and a little bit less developed
in ICT governance
and ICT frameworks.
And then some countries are
doing quite, quite well in both.
But ultimately, though, it
takes both the ICT governance
and the legislative framework
and the policy framework
and the cyber security and the
trust as well as the technology.
Some of the changes from a legal
standpoint and a risk standpoint
for cyber security and
understanding the risks
to governments and countries.
Everyone recognizes
that the Anonymous mask,
really quite an active
organization.
And some say one of the first
or the first non country
country, actually.
But they provide a threat
to many types of countries
as well as local governments.
From where I'm from
in south Florida,
the Fort Lauderdale government
passed legislation on loitering.
It had to do with the
homeless, but they were trying
to help the homeless,
but also pass this
anti-loitering legislation.
And Anonymous actually
defaced their website.
Also, too, attacking many
of the pharmaceutical
companies and larger firms.
The risk on the bottom
right of the insider,
we'll talk about this a little
bit later, not in the context
of Edward Snowden, but in the
context of different perceptions
of cyber security from
country to country.
The upper left was one of the --
a conviction by the U.S.
government Department
of Justice.
This gentleman led
a ring in Estonia,
as it turns out, on
click thru fraud.
And so they made tens
of millions of dollars,
and the chart there shows that
the companies that they bought
with the proceeds from the
click thru fraud that they had.
And then the bottom left, the
Chinese group who attacked some
of our companies, Westinghouse,
U.S. Steel, in cyber espionage,
industrial espionage, and
we'll talk about that too,
and different perceptions,
in a little bit.
And then lastly this
is a current one.
You can see the quite
large award or reward,
$1 million offered by the FBI.
This gentleman was running
fraudulent car auctions here.
He lived overseas, but here.
And so people were buying cars
online and paying for the cars,
but there was ultimately no car.
And so the U.S. government --
He's one of the most wanted,
the cyber most wanted,
by the FBI.
So a lot of risk to
citizens, and a lot of risk
to critical infrastructure.
Last year a topic that was
in the news a lot is the
risk to the electric grid.
So electric grid is changing.
So previously over the years
it was one directional,
power flowing one way.
It wasn't very IT reliant.
It had industrial
control systems
with many, many years of life.
Not connected to networks
or to the internet.
Now the power system
is different.
So power goes two ways,
both from the power company
to the users, and also for those
with solar power back
to the power company.
Also more and more reliant
on information technology.
So this example from
Russian territory,
part of the Ukrainian power
grid was shut down for
about three hours or so.
And it was of interest
both because of --
Primarily because
it was demonstrating
that someone could indeed
take down a power company.
Part of the sophistication of
this was that it was planned,
and the reconnaissance
that it took.
Part of it wasn't
that sophisticated.
More the click through
type of thing.
But the U.S. government very
oriented towards the risks
to the power system as well
as to the risk to many --
much of our critical
infrastructure.
One of the kind of
interesting things
about the U.S. is both our
distributed governance as well
as distributed approach to
critical infrastructure.
So in the U.S. we have
50,000 or so water companies,
more than 3,000 electric
utilities.
Many are very, very big,
and very sophisticated.
Many are much, much smaller.
Oftentimes they're
municipal owned.
And then there's the national
government responsibility
as well as state government
from public service commissions.
So part of the challenge here
in the U.S. is how all
these things come together.
Part of the other challenges
is the technology itself.
Sometimes with operating
systems and windows,
sometimes with flash drives,
sometimes with -- at the banks.
Adopting new technology.
And sometimes, as I mentioned,
with the electric grid.
This is an interesting
demonstration which I was going
to show, but I'm not
using my computer.
Has anyone seen the
Aurora demonstration
from Idaho National Lab?
So it's a demonstration
of the connection
between physical security
and internet security.
And part of the motivation
for the Japan Society 5.0 is
the increasing convergence
of physical and cyber
and internet.
But what this demonstration
was in 2007,
and this is a CNN video,
is by online opening
and closing the relays
out of phase
with the electric grid they
were able to cause this
to start shaking slowly.
And ultimately end
up smoking like that.
So it was a very
visual demonstration,
and part of the objective
was to do something visual.
But the point being that there's
this connection between physical
and cyber that's becoming
more and more relevant.
So right before we were talking
a little bit about drones,
so there there's a connection.
Many of the drones operated from
ground, and the drone flying.
Autonomous vehicles
such as cars.
Robots and robotics.
And even artificial
intelligence.
All of these things
with more autonomy,
and oftentimes a
physical aspect to them.
Okay. What makes the threat so
-- Part of what makes the threat
so challenging is
the asymmetry of it.
So the systems that we have
today are really complicated.
Millions and millions of lines
of code, often of custom code
and some open source, some
legacy code, and contrast
that -- Oftentimes malware
can be as small as 125 lines.
So relatively easy to
duplicate, relatively easy
to sell non sophisticated types.
But really a contrast with
the systems that we have.
This is a DARPA slide to try
to demonstrate the asymmetry
or the advantage sometimes
with today's technology
that an attacker might have.
So the questions for the
country and for a company
and for an individual, too,
is how secure actually are you
as a company or as a government
or as a home, a house,
or a family.
And how do you answer that?
Which is difficult
because it's a risk issue.
Are we more secure this
year than last year?
And how do we know?
And how much more secure
would we be if we spent
so much extra in budget dollars?
And how much more
secure would we be
if we adopt these processes,
practices, and technologies?
So these are difficult questions
to answer, and that's part
of the challenge or objective
with IT governance is
to develop a way or to have
an approach within a company
or a government to answer
these types of questions.
And then the answers to
these types of questions lead
to the cyber security plan
or program for the year,
and the budget, and
the initiatives.
So a country's overall cyber
security strategy is much,
much broader than this,
but at the company level
this is a big part of it.
So part of answering
that is to look
at what the actual
cost is to a company.
And there's two types.
So there's a type of
cost that there might be
for a critical infrastructure
breach,
and that is more
the financial cost
from a personal type
information breach.
But let's look at one example
from Wyndham Worldwide,
and see what the direct
and indirect costs are.
So Wyndham owns Ramada, I
think, and I think Day's Inn,
and some other ones
[inaudible] big hotel chain.
And quite a good one.
So they had a major breach
about 2010 or so with the theft
of millions of credit cards.
So a major breach.
Not as big as some,
but quite big.
And so there was the cost to
the consumer of the monitoring
which they covered,
but also the cost
for whoever lost
-- identity loss.
But also there was many, many
other costs to the company.
So the Federal Trade Commission
in the U.S. has a very
large cyber security role,
and it derives from
fair trade practices.
And so they -- And also
how you present yourself
to your customers,
whether you're truthful
in presenting yourself.
So they've had dozens of
actions, some of which have been
that companies haven't been up
front about what they're doing
with data or what
cyber risks they have.
But in this case there was a
theft of personal information,
and so the FTC sent a
request to Wyndham Worldwide
to provide information.
Over several years -- So
Wyndham Worldwide provided
over 1,000 pages
of documentation.
So it affected through
the burden
of answering the questions
the company operations.
Ultimately FTC filed a
lawsuit which they settled.
So just with the FTC a
large amount of costs,
but Wyndham at this point
isn't complete with the FTC.
So the FTC now has oversight on
Wyndham's systems for 20 years.
Wyndham has to provide reporting
annually and to the FTC
about how they're
providing cyber security
and how they know.
But also Wyndham
ended up with lawsuits
from state attorney generals,
and a shareholder
[inaudible] lawsuit
which was ultimately dismissed,
but shareholders
asking the company,
and the company wouldn't or
didn't, to sue executives
for not performing their cyber
security responsibilities.
So Target, too, class
action settlement.
Paying the banks also,
not just the card holders.
Another one.
This was -- Oh.
The Home Depot shareholder
derived suit.
So a number of very large costs
of the companies developing
a cyber security strategy,
but also developing
policies and procedures
to protect the customers,
to protect their employees,
protect their operations.
But also more and more the risk
from the Federal
Trade Commission
and other government agencies
who have oversight
responsibility.
So these agencies,
to some extent,
are driving cyber security
[inaudible] of our companies.
Okay. So what are the
company's key assets,
and how does a company go
about developing a
cyber security program?
One of the best ways
I've seen --
A gentleman who's been
CISO at a major bank
and a major power company,
and now at a major
pharmaceutical company,
is to develop a consensus
amongst the executives
as to what the key assets
are within the company.
Key information assets.
So much different
in the power company
than in the pharmaceutical.
The pharmaceutical company the
intellectual property as well
as the personal information,
the power company the
control systems and the
like as well as the financials.
But develop a consensus
across the organization
as to what the key
information assets are,
and what risks they
face, and then how to go
about protecting them, and what
budget dollars do they need.
Another thing he also does is
have an external assessment
of the cyber security.
And he's evolved it, and so
now he partners with companies
from other industries, has
someone come in to assess them
on a number of attributes,
and then does a comparison
across all the companies
and gives him leverage
with the board.
But you can see some
of the assets here.
A plane schematic
on he bottom right
which was actually
stolen by the Chinese.
Upper left credit
card information,
and the bottom left
power company.
So these are some
of the elements
that this company has
benchmarked against others.
So a lot of it is
leadership and governance.
So policies, the
organization, HR security.
Some of it's technology,
cryptography,
communications security.
And then some of
it is compliance
and incident management.
One of the new ones that
many companies are taking
up partially post Target
is supplier relationships,
including many of the larger
companies here in Washington.
So going back, reviewing
their existing contracts,
the ones with the largest
vendors that might place them
at most risk from
cyber security,
and where possible
renegotiating part of it.
And setting up a process
for any new contract
if it exceeds some
threshold with cyber risk
that the CISO signs off on it.
And then this is
how they organize.
This is a 100,000 person
company quite distributed
around the world.
But you can see it's not --
Strategy and architecture,
enterprise risk, privacy
incident response,
and third party are
the main parts.
And then kind of interestingly,
and I think different
than many companies,
although there's more
and more doing it this
way, the actual day
to day technology part
of cyber security,
like managing firewalls and
alike, is done by the CIO,
the information technology
group.
So this group, much
more strategic
and much more engaged
with the board.
And it's what this gentleman
did at the very large bank
and the power company too.
So I think this is a really
good approach at a company level
to how to go about it.
Did anyone read the
Inspector General's report
on OPM, the OPM aftermath?
It actually reads like a roadmap
for the Chinese, unfortunately.
But it talks about a lot
of these types of things.
So the not having CISO, the
cyber security staff that was
that OPM not being very elevated
and being able to connect
with executives, not having
two factor authentication.
So a lot of the things which are
good practices can go a long way
towards strengthening
cyber security.
Okay. One of the more important
things, I think, but --
is leadership in cyber security,
and really elevating the role.
Especially where it's possible
in large organizations.
So we're working with
the cities and counties.
We had a workshop for Virginia.
And so many of the
Virginia cities
and counties are quite small,
and oftentimes don't have
a cyber security executive.
And sometimes, too, don't
even have an IT staff person.
So there's -- The size is
really, really important.
But for the larger organizations
the leadership is integral.
So in the U.S. itself it's
had a quite long focus
on elevating the role of CIO,
and this is international too.
Many countries now have
national ICT plans,
and many countries
have either legislation
or policy requiring a CIO
in government ministries
or agencies.
And some of the legislation
goes so far as to require CIO
and in private sector
companies like Japan's does.
And we'll see this being
adopted in cyber security.
So in the U.S. our first
act was in the late 1990s,
the Clinger-Cohen Act
which required a CIO
in government agencies, and
also established the federal CIO
council for coordinating IT
across government agencies
on issues of commonality
such as cyber security,
enterprise architecture,
and human capacity building.
Over the years the role
didn't necessarily turn
out as envisioned, and in some
agencies the CIO didn't have
budget authority or in some
agencies there's multiple CIOs
who didn't necessarily all
report up to the main CIO.
So Commerce is a
good example of this.
So Commerce, a wonderful
agency with this fantastic work
and multiple organizations
within it such as [inaudible]
and patent and trademark
and [inaudible].
Some of those receive their
budget through user fees,
and have some degree
of autonomy.
So within Commerce the NOAA CIO
and the patent and trademark
over the years not
necessarily reporting
in to the Commerce CIO.
So this being a way
to strengthen CIO
leadership in government.
More and more organizations
and government agencies,
and this is worldwide
too, elevating the role
of chief information
security officer
to a peer level with CIO.
It varies by industry,
and it varies by degree
of cyber security maturity.
It varies by size
of the organization.
So the gentleman from the
pharmaceutical company,
he's a peer of the CIO and a
peer of the CFO, the CISO role.
And state -- And county and
state government, it varies.
In Arlington County the
CISO reports to the CIO,
and in other counties
that isn't so.
There's more of a peer --
There can be a conflict that the
CIO oriented towards moving --
developing services quickly,
and customer service,
and product delivery,
the CISO for security.
But it can work both ways,
but there can be a conflict.
This is a project we did
through the International
Science Foundation.
We interviewed executives
across the country, cyber and IT
as well as other executives, in
regard to the core competencies
for the most important
core competencies
for chief information
security officers.
And talked to both government
and private sector and local,
state, and national government.
And we organized
them by perspectives.
And, as you can see here
too, as with the CIO,
and as with the large company,
many of these are non technical.
So leading large organizations,
building high performance teams,
compliance, communications
being at the top.
One interesting thing.
We had a question, "Do you
think technology knowledge is
as important or more
important than leadership?"
And leadership background
and communications.
And the overwhelming answer
was that they are both
for CISO equally important.
That some technology and
technology knowledge and ability
to communicate about technology
both to staff as well as boards
as well as leadership
being quite important.
That was part of the report.
So what are countries doing then
for cyber security strategy,
and what are the implications
for international relations?
According to ITU, about 75
countries now have cyber
security strategies
and policies,
although on their website some
of them are quite old or dated.
But about 75 countries.
About 90% of countries
have national ICT policies
and strategies.
So a subset having
cyber security policies
and strategies.
But mostly they follow along
and address some of the topics
of this one from Singapore.
So Singapore is similar to
Estonia competing on IT.
And oriented towards
being a smart society.
So some of their major
initiatives are hardening
security, developing
the workforce,
working internationally
which we'll talk about,
and public outreach
and awareness.
So many of the types of things
or a subset of the types
of things that we do here or
that are really important to us.
Countries compete
on cyber security.
So Korea has as an objective
of its industrial strategy
being a world leader in internet
of things, and developing
a vibrant Korean internet
of things, ecosystem.
One of the pillars of that
strategy is IOT security.
So becoming a leader, world
leader, in IOT security
as a means to become
a world leader in IOT.
Here's kind of a --
It's really quite small,
but as with ICT national
plans, evolution of plans
and strategies over the
years, this is Singapore's,
but we've had something
similar here.
So we have had an evolution of
national plans and strategies.
One major difference
to highlight, I think,
is the difference in,
well, size obviously,
and national geography.
But also the difference
in our approach
to government derives
somewhat from our size.
So we have the municipal,
the state, and the national.
Much different than Singapore
which has one government.
So here we have the national
approach with the roles of FBI,
DHS, and director of
national intelligence.
There's state roles, and then
there's also the roles of local
and municipal government
in cyber security.
And then those coming together.
One other interesting aside on
the differences that we have.
So the states.
Many of the electric companies
and water companies are
municipally owned, but also all
of them are licensed
through the state public
service commissions.
So state public service
commissions are beginning
to take a role in cyber security
and overseeing the industries
and companies that
they regulate.
But it's really kind
of remarkable how these public
service commissions differ
across the country both in
their makeup and how they come
to be, and in their mission.
So in some states
they're appointed.
In some states they're
elected statewide.
elected in the regions.
And in some states the
mission is real narrow,
and in Mississippi, for example,
the role of the public
service commission,
one of the prime roles, is to
foster economic development.
So really very, very
different across the country
as they look to take
a cyber role.
Connecticut now requires
annual reports
from the Connecticut
Public Service Commission,
from their companies that they
regulate in an annual meeting
with the service commission.
Others are different stages.
So, as I said, many
countries have policies.
These are just three.
The U.K. Chile.
And on the left, Japan.
A lot of commonality, but also
some differences in approach
and differences in
emphasis which we'll talk
about a little bit more when we
compare U.S. and China or talk
about the U.S/China
relationship.
Just on the role of the CIO,
for example, so as I mentioned,
the Japanese law for CIO
requires private sector
companies to have them.
About two years ago Korea
through legislation
started requiring CISOs,
chief information
security officers,
in financial companies
over a certain size.
So different than here, although
here in the U.S. now state
of New York requires CISOs
in financial service
companies over a certain size.
So again regulation really
driving a lot of this.
ITU helping countries,
developing countries,
develop national cyber
security strategies.
And here's the elements.
Number one is similar to
private sector companies
and boards having engagements
and accountability by the board.
Having a coordinator.
Having a focal point.
Legal framework for
cyber security,
including cyber crime and trust.
Incident response
for the country.
Awareness and education.
Building on public/private
partnerships.
Skills and training
and cooperation.
Singapore, for example, has one
other one that's not on this one
from IT which is innovation.
So Singapore looking to compete
in the cyber security industry,
and wanting to be an
innovator in that.
But so many of the
countries working
with ITU are taking
this approach.
We had a Humphrey Fellow
visitor last year for six weeks
from Nigeria, from
OAU University.
And I -- He was working
on a project.
So Nigeria just recently
passed a cyber security act,
but their challenge, as
many developing countries,
they don't have the
institutional foundation
to implement something
like that readily.
So the project he was working
on was to develop the --
strengthen the institution
so that they can actually
implement the act they have.
And their university, also a
World Bank Center of Excellence
for cyber in West Africa.
Okay. Some of the trends I
think, some are technology
and then some are
policy and international.
One is the role of artificial
intelligence and big data.
So the systems and the network
elements are generating millions
or actually billions
of data instances.
It's impossible to hire enough
staff to look at all of these.
So the path is artificial
intelligence and being able
to analyze a lot of the
cyber data computationally.
Becoming less reliant on
analysts, and using analysts
for the really -- things
that need a lot of expertise.
So the schools are --
have many cyber students,
but just demand is
much, much too great.
Also too, for example, smaller
companies can't afford a
cyber analyst.
Or smaller water companies.
So automation being
really, really important
and a big part of
the path forward.
Also on technology,
and I don't have it,
but I think the interaction
of hardware and software,
like some of the companies
are working on such as Intel,
and [inaudible] with their
[inaudible] but many others too.
Samsung. Building
part of the security
in to the hardware is part of --
an important part of
the path forward too.
Another part is international
cooperation
at the multilateral
level, and we'll wrap
up with the bilateral level.
So many fantastic
initiatives worldwide.
The bottom right
highlights a challenge
of cyber security in general.
So countries have
different perceptions
of what cyber security is
and what the internet is.
Amongst each other, it varies
somewhat east and west,
somewhat developed
and developing,
some even amongst neighbors
much different perceptions.
There's also differing
perceptions on governance
of the internet which
comes in to play too.
The U.S. having a central
role since the start of it,
but many countries --
And tying in to the view
of cyber security thinking
that the role should
be more distributed.
This is a wonderful book
on the bottom right.
So in Estonia there's a
NATO cyber security center
of excellence, and they put out
a first version of this manual.
It's by academics,
and it's non binding.
The first one was on cyber
war, but this is more on day
to day cyber operations and
things like sovereignty.
And they go through issue
by issue, and they talk
about issues, whether there's
a consensus amongst all the
experts, including from the U.S.
and Russia and China and Europe
and South America
and Africa and Asia,
but also whether it's just
disagreement amongst the experts
and not a consensus.
About 10 years ago or a little
bit longer, the ITU wanted --
The secretary of the ITU wanted
to undertake a cyber
security project amongst the
ITU membership.
The ITU has done a lot more
on cyber since, but he wanted
to come up with a non
controversial project
that all the members
could participate in.
And the only one that he
was able to get an agreement
that he thought he could
get a consensus on was
on pedophiles, online predators.
So that was the one where there
was a consensus amongst all
countries that -- on
what it was and the risk.
But it's not just NATO.
So [inaudible] has an active
cyber program World Bank
funding, World Bank
centers of excellence.
OECD is doing quite a lot.
European Union, United Nations.
So the international
community quite active in it,
and part of it is
technology innovation,
but part of it is strengthening
the institutional capacity
of the countries.
Part of it too is security
by design so that software
and devices as they are taken
to the market are secure
and not at as much risk.
So part of the challenge of
this is differing motivations,
and who actually pays, and
economic disincentives.
So if you're producing a device
and it's very low margin,
and you need to get it in to
the market, and you're not going
to bear the cost of a cyber
security breach, for example,
if it's taken over
for a DDoS attack,
your motivation isn't
necessarily
in to putting a lot
of security on it.
So aligning economic motivations
with the technology
development is a big case too.
A better example
of that, I think,
is electronic medical records.
It's similar economic incentive.
So pretty much everyone
agrees there's a public good
if everyone has electronic --
a portable electronic
medical record.
You're able to go from doctor to
doctor and hospital to hospital.
But there's multiple
stakeholders
and there's not enough
incentive or motivation
for any one stakeholder
to fund it over the years.
So not necessarily an
incentive for the hospitals.
It's different now
with the government,
the government payment system.
But not incentive
for the hospitals.
Insurance companies
have a motivation,
but can't carry the data
for having it implemented.
The patients like it, but
are not necessarily going
to pay for it.
And so that's part of the
backbone of why we haven't --
why we don't have it here.
So our government, 2009, part
of the Affordable Care Act,
implemented that you would get
a bonus if you implemented them
on Medicare and Medicaid,
and over time a penalty.
So the government using
positive and negative incentives
to try to drive behavior.
But over time security
by design --
Multilateral security
agreements.
So European Union, for example,
looking at digital Europe
and harmonizing some
of the approaches
to cyber across the countries.
Really important initiative.
And then lastly, bilateral ones.
My point, though, and wrapping
up with this one, is not so much
to highlight the agreement.
This was from 2015,
the two [inaudible],
but to highlight the
differences and point of view.
So the agreement
itself was this.
So this was right after the
-- The five, I believe it was.
Chinese military were indicted
in Pennsylvania for hacking
in to industrial espionage for
Westinghouse and U.S. Steel.
So shortly after the
indictment there was a meeting
between President
Obama and President Xi,
and they had this agreement.
So timely coordination.
Cooperating and remaining
consistent with national laws.
Neither country's government
will support cyber theft
of IP, which was new.
And both sides making
a common effort.
But the background to this is
that historically there's
been differences in the view
of what espionage is
between the two countries.
And also differences in the view
of how the internet
should be governed.
So the Chinese view
historically has been espionage
under a broad umbrella,
and so industrial
espionage is just part
of overall national espionage.
It's something a country does to
strengthen its national position
or national competitiveness.
And so our view is a little
bit different historically,
that there's national
espionage that we do,
but that industrial
espionage is separate
and not sanctioned
internationally.
So that's a very broad
divide between the two.
And even within our definition
the OPM one may well have --
be considered espionage
under a U.S. view.
But the industrial
ones of Westinghouse
and U.S. Steel are not.
So this agreement to the
extent it is followed,
actually China agreeing
that IP may well --
type of espionage may
well be different.
So these types of
agreements have potential too.
That's cyber security being part
of a real broad umbrella
internationally,
and part of international
relations.
Ultimately, though, it's the
intersection of better systems
and better technology
and innovation
and cyber security along
with increased cyber security
leadership and governance,
policy and legislation,
which will come together
to make the world safer
from a cyber perspective.
So I hope that was
somewhat interesting.
And if anyone has any
questions, that would be great.
>> Tomoko Steen: Questions?
>> J.P. Auffret: Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> J.P. Auffret: so the --
With quantum computing
there's some risk
that our current encryption
approaches will become obsolete
quite quickly.
Yeah. There is -- Yes.
There is a view that
there's that risk,
and NIST has a program now for
developing encryption algorithms
that would work in a
quantum computing world.
So the U.S. government is
concerned that as demonstrated
through the research they're
funding -- I think too --
This is from very far away.
That Chinese government seems
to be advancing quite rapidly
in quantum communications
with the satellite they have,
and quantum computing.
And so I think probably from
our standpoint we would do well
with, you know, further
investment or focus on it.
But it's an important
area, I think.
Oh, yes.
>> Speaker 2: There's a lot
of talk about a shortage
of qualified security
professionals
that [inaudible]
they can't afford
to pay them [inaudible] wages.
Are there some recommendations
that you have
for what [inaudible]
can do to invest better,
and more particularly
[inaudible] workforce?
>> J.P. Auffret: Oh.
I think there's quite
a few things.
I think part of it is external,
and then part of it's internal.
So there's -- So the government
has some fantastic programs
working with the universities
to -- Well, foster --
enhance education, cyber
security education,
and also increase the
number of students going
in to cyber security both in
undergraduate and graduate
and increasingly K through 12.
And so I think that the
universities are both training
and educating a fair number
of students I don't
think will ever be enough
because of the issue
with technology.
But then I think it's
also somewhat difficult
to join the government.
So I think for students looking
to join the government there's
fantastic programs to --
for internships which
our students do.
Many of our students have a
challenge with the process,
although many of the
agencies are very helpful.
But the long process.
There's also the chicken and
egg issue with clearances
that can be a bit
of a challenge.
And then one other thing
I've noticed in the very,
very large ones, agencies,
is that career pathing --
Some of the agencies are
fantastic on career pathing
and cyber, and some not so.
So I can give two examples.
Not the name of the
agency, but two examples.
So one a quite large agency.
Does fantastic things, but they
-- And this is hard everywhere,
in private sector companies too.
Struggling a little
bit with technical
versus managerial career paths,
and how to keep somebody
challenged and interested
and on an advancing career
path in the technical field
who really loves it and
is really offering a lot.
Or how someone can try
a managerial career path
and then go back.
And so that's hard on a
consulting company too.
So I think that's an example.
And another company or agency,
and this is one of the ones
that does offensive
too, and cyber threat --
And so their part of the
issue is organizationally
where the cyber security
group put --
There's not much
career advancement.
And that the offensive
is working
with the more current
technologies.
So everyone wants to grab
a take towards that too.
So I think it's a little bit
working with the universities,
and then a little bit
to ease the way in,
and then a little bit to --
the career pathing issue.
What do you think?
>> Speaker 2: Yeah.
I know there's a lot of
talk about opening up some
of the programs like
the [inaudible]
for [inaudible] two
year institutions
or even short term programs.
I don't know.
>> J.P. Auffret: Well, the
CyberCorps one is fantastic,
and I think connecting
more towards --
with the community
colleges would be great.
The National Science Foundation,
the core competency project
that we had, that was
a CyberCorps project.
The community colleges,
they're training
and working with hands on.
So I think also too
-- I think there's --
Well, many I've talked to
it's kind of mixed reviews
of [inaudible] and the
U.S. digital service,
but I think those types
of initiatives have potential
too for cyber security.
Yeah. So I think all those.
[ Inaudible ]
>> J.P. Auffret: Yeah.
The FDA is quite active.
Oh. It's cyber security
for medical devices.
The FDA is quite active in it.
It's a hard topic, I
think, because part
of with the approach
to approvals --
So if a device is similar,
it has a rapid approval
or an expedited approval path.
But it's very difficult
to say that software
on one device is similar to
software on another device.
But the FDA is looking
at enhanced regulation
of medical devices according
to the risk obviously.
And then also some testing
approach for medical devices
and medical device security.
And also increased guidance
on issues such as patching.
So I think all of those, but
it's a real challenging area,
the -- Everyone see some
of the examples in the news
over the last years or so
that got highlighted
with medical devices?
I think the one that had the
most news play was an infusion
pump, the drip, where it was
hacked and someone was able
to turn it on and off remotely.
They didn't do it,
but they demonstrated
that it was possible.
Actually, one of our masters
degree programs we have,
they have a capstone
class project.
They did a medical
device project,
and they tested heart monitors.
They put it on themselves,
and were able to --
Some of them had no
security on them.
They were able to monitor
someone's heart rate
from like 100 yards away.
So I think the manufacturers
are getting better,
but it's a big challenge.
And it's a big challenge
for the hospitals too.
I think the hospitals are
going to drive a lot of it,
and then one thing I
didn't mention is the role
of insurance and
cyber insurance.
So cyber insurance is
becoming more and more common.
And it's being driven partially
by boards to help manage risk.
It partially provides an
external party that comes in
and does underwriting
assessment in some manner.
So it helps you benchmark, but
I think it also has an impact
on medical device companies
who are selling medical devices
that could have a problem.
Federal Trade Commission
too has a very large role.
But it's a big issue.
Oh, yes?
>> Speaker 4: I don't know that
I want to focus on [inaudible]
but it seems that cyber is an
area where [inaudible] ahead.
You can't afford to fall
behind if you invest more
and more resources in
just maintaining what you
already have.
Is that -- Do you see
that having an effect
on rate of implementation?
Some countries may be
[inaudible] investments.
And then [inaudible].
>> J.P. Auffret: That's
an interesting question
because I think it
ties to the role of ICT
in a country and in society.
So I think every
country faces a risk.
If -- As Japan is moving towards
society 5.0 and Singapore
and Estonia and us,
that countries
who aren't ICT oriented
risk falling further
and further behind and
becoming less competitive.
And so given that, and given
how important cyber security is,
I think it's imperative
for the countries
to be cyber security
oriented too.
What holds them back,
though, is partially cost.
So a lot of the technologies
are very, very expensive,
and take some expertise.
So the countries
have a challenge both
with the new ICT they're doing,
but also in the cost and how
to go about the cyber security.
There's -- Through
-- ITU in Singapore.
There's a group who has a focus
on open source cyber
security tools.
There's many, and they
don't do everything,
but they do some things, and --
But there's a challenge
of putting them together.
But there's that challenge too.
Many, many companies now have
30 or 40 technologies that --
sometimes which conflict.
And so some of the research
now is in company initiatives
or using the phrase
orchestrating cyber security
technologies so they're
compatible.
[ Inaudible ]
>> J.P. Auffret: Oh.
I have an opinion.
I don't think so.
I don't think there's
-- I don't think the --
I don't think there would be the
national will that it would take
to actually do that, given how
we're organized and the role
of the private sector
and things like that.
So I don't think.
But it's a really
fascinating question.
The electronic medical
record, the value of it is --
on the black market is much
higher than a credit card.
So credit card is
relatively low.
But medical record much,
much higher because if you steal
someone's medical record it will
be -- You can put
bills through on it.
It will be six months
before it's caught.
A credit card might be
stopped the next day,
but you can Medicaid
or Medicare fraud
or insurance fraud
six months or a year.
So it's much more valuable.
One kind of note on that.
In Virginia, 7 of the 10
largest hospitals have Epic.
The Epic electronic
medical records system.
But they're for the most
part on different versions.
So they're not compatible
amongst each other.
>> Tomoko Steen: So please join
me in thanking the speaker.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.